>> OKAY.
STAND BY ON THIS, HERE IS
PRESIDENT BIDEN TALKING ABOUT
THE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
FORGIVENESS.
>> WE BECAME NOT FIGURATIVELY,
LITERALLY, THE BEST EDUCATED
PUBLIC IN THE WORLD, AND BETTER
PREPARED THAN ANY OTHER NATION,
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE WERE SO
SUCCESSFUL AND HAVE BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL, BUT AS YOU'VE ALL
OBSERVED, OTHER NATIONS HAVE
CAUGHT UP.
IN THE 21st CENTURY, IN MY VIEW,
I THINK THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS 12 YEARS OF UNIVERSAL
EDUCATION IS NOT ENOUGH, AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE OUT COMPETED
BY THE REST OF THE WORLD IF WE
DON'T TAKE ACTION.
BUT HERE'S THE DEAL, THE COST OF
EDUCATION BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL HAS
GONE UP SIGNIFICANTLY.
THE TOTAL COST TO ATTEND A
PUBLIC FOUR-YEAR UNIVERSITY HAS
TRIPLED, NEARLY TRIPLED IN 40
YEARS, TRIPLED.
INSTEAD OF PROPERLY FUNDING
PUBLIC COLLEGES, MANY STATES
HAVE CUT BACK THEIR SUPPORT.
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT THAT
IN THE OVAL.
MANY STATES HAVE CUT BACK
SUPPORT FOR THEIR STATE
UNIVERSITIES LEAVING STUDENTS TO
PICK UP MORE OF THE TAB.
IN 50 YEARS, FOR 50 YEARS, PELL
GRANTS HAD BEEN A KEY WAY FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES,
PARTICULARLY THOSE EARNING LESS
THAN $60,000 A YEAR TO SEND
THEIR KIDS TO COLLEGE.
THOSE PELL GRANTS USED TO COVER
80%, 80% OF THE COST OF GOING TO
A PUBLIC FOUR-YEAR COLLEGE.
TODAY PELL GRANTS COVER ROUGHLY
32%.
THAT'S ONE-THIRD OF THE COST AS
OPPOSED TO BEFORE.
IT MATTERS.
I REMEMBER WALKING UP, MY DAD
LIKE PROBABLY A LOT OF YOUR
FOLKS CARED A LOT ABOUT YOUR
EDUCATION.
MY DAD'S GREATEST REGRET WAS
THAT HE NEVER GOT TO GO TO
COLLEGE, AND MY DADS AFTER VERY
WELL-READ MAN, PARTICULARLY
HISTORY AND -- BUT IT WAS A
GREAT REGRET.
HE ALWAYS SAID, JOEY, YOU'RE
GOING TO BE A COLLEGE MAN.
AND I'D SAY, DAD, WHAT DOES THAT
MATTER.
YOU CAN STILL GET FIRED IF
YOU'RE A COLLEGE MAN.
HE SAID, YEAH, BUT THEY CAN
NEVER TAKE IT AWAY FROM YOU.
THEY CAN NEVER TAKE YOUR
EDUCATION AWAY.
AND I REMEMBER MY SENIOR YEAR I
GOT INTO ONE OF THE LITTLE IVYS,
AND I GOT INTO A NUMBER OF
SCHOOLS AND WE WERE TRYING TO
GET THE MONEY EVEN WITH
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO BE ABLE
TO GO THERE.
WE HAD FOUR KIDS, ALL OF US
WANTING TO GO TO SCHOOL, AND I
REMEMBER GOING DOWN AFTER A
BASEBALL GAME.
I WENT TO A REALLY GOOD SCHOOL
IN CLAYMONT, DELAWARE, ON THE
PENNSYLVANIA BORDER, AND I DROVE
DOWN TO NEWARK, DELAWARE, MY DAD
WORKED AT AN AUTOMOBILE AGENCY,
AND I WALKED IN AND I HAD MY
SPIKES -- BECAUSE THE REASON I
WAS GOING DOWN, WHEN YOUR DAD
WORKS IN AN AUTOMOBILE AGENCY,
THE GREAT ADVANTAGE, YOU GET A
NEW CAR TO GO TO THE PROM OR A
GOOD USED CAR.
YOU THINK I'M JOKING, I'M NOT
JOKING.
AND SO I WENT DOWN IN MY '51
PLYMOUTH WITH BEACH TOWELS FOR
SEAT COVERS, AND I HAD MY
UNIFORM ON, MY SPIKES OFF.
I RAN AND THE WOMAN'S NAME WAS
MARY, WHERE'S DAD, HE'S OUT IN
THE LANE, IN THE REPAIR SHOP.
TRUE STORY.
MY DAD WAS A WELL-DRESSED
REFINED FELLOW, AND HE WAS
PACING BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
THE BIG GARAGE DOOR GOING INTO
THE REPAIR SHOP, AND THE DOOR
GOING OUT OF THE SHOWROOM.
AND HE LOOKED UP, HE SAID, JOEY,
HONEY, I'M SO SORRY.
I'M SO SORRY.
I THOUGHT, GOD, SOMETHING
HAPPENED.
THIS WAS BEFORE CELL PHONES.
I THOUGHT SOMEONE HAPPENED TO
ONE OF MY BROTHERS OR MY SISTER
OR MY MOM OR SOMETHING.
I SAID, WHAT'S THE MATTER DAD,
HE SAID I WENT TO SEE, THE GUY
NAME'S NAME WAS CHARLIE DELCHER,
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE FARMERS
BANK, A STATE OWNED BANK THAT
DID A LOT OF FINANCING OF PEOPLE
WANTING TO PURCHASE A CAR.
I WENT TO CHARLIE AND ASKED TO
BORROW THE MONEY.
HE SAID HE WON'T LEND IT TO ME.
HE SAID, I'M SO ASHAMED, I'M SO
DAMN ASHAMED, YOU KNOW, MY DAD
WOULD -- YOU KNOW, MY DAD WAS
LIKE MILLIONS OF PARENTS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WANT TO HELP THEIR KIDS GET TO
SCHOOL, BUT THERE WAS NO WAY TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE HE BELIEVED AS
I DO, THAT EDUCATION IS A TICKET
TO A BETTER LIFE.
BUT SOMETHING JILL AND I, KAMALA
AND DOUG UNDERSTAND DEEPLY, AND
THE VAST MAJORITY OF YOU DO AS
WELL.
OVER TIME THAT TICKET HAS BECOME
TOO EXPENSIVE FOR TOO MANY
AMERICANS.
ALL THIS MEANS IS THE ENTIRE --
AN ENTIRE GENERATION IS NOW
SADDLED WITH UNSUSTAINABLE DEBT
IN EXCHANGE FOR AN ATTEMPT, AT
LEAST, AT A COLLEGE DEGREE.
THE BURDEN IS SO HEAVY, EVEN IF
YOU GRADUATE, YOU MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE MIDDLE CLASS LIFE
THAT THE COLLEGE DEGREE ONCE
PROVIDED.
MANY PEOPLE, MANY PEOPLE CAN'T
QUALIFY FOR A MORTGAGE TO BUY A
HOME BECAUSE THE DEBT THEY
CONTINUE TO CARRY.
THEY, YOU KNOW, THEY CARRY --
IT'S TOO HIGH, THEY CAN'T COME
UP WITH A DOWN PAYMENT, ANYWAY.
A LOT OF FOLKS ARE EVEN PUTTING
OFF STARTING FAMILIES BECAUSE OF
THE COST.
AND THE DREAM OF STARTING YOUR
OWN BUSINESS IS JUST WAY OFF IN
THE DISTANCE, WITH A DEBT THAT
YOU'RE SADDLED WITH.
MANY OF YOU HAD TO LEAVE SCHOOL
BECAUSE FINANCIAL STRAIN WAS
MUCH TOO HIGH.
ABOUT A THIRD OF THE BORROWERS
HAVE DEBT BUT NO DEGREE.
AND WORST OF BOTH WORLDS, DEBT
AND NO DEGREE.
THE BURDEN IS ESPECIALLY HEAVY
ON BLACK AND HISPANIC BORROWERS,
WHO ON AVERAGE HAVE LESS FAMILY
WEALTH TO PAY FOR IT.
THEY DON'T OWN THEIR HOMES TO
BORROW AGAINST, TO BE ABLE TO
PAY FOR COLLEGE.
AND THE PANDEMIC ONLY MADE
THINGS WORSE.
BUT WE RESPONDED AGGRESSIVELY TO
THE PANDEMIC TO MINIMIZE THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THE HARM OF
COVID IMPOSED ON INDIVIDUALS,
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES.
YOU ALL WERE THERE.
LOOK, WE INCREASED UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS FOR WORKERS WHO WERE
LAID OFF.
WE PROVIDED LOANS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES SO THEY COULD STAY
AFLOAT AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
WE PROVIDED ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE
TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE.
REMEMBER THOSE LONG LINES YOU
GUYS FILMED OF CARS, DECENT
LOOKING CARS, NICE CARS, JUST
WAITING FOR A BOX OF FOOD TO BE
PUT IN THE TRUNK.
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
WAITING FOR OVER AN HOUR TO GET
FOOD IN A TRUNK.
WE PROVIDED RENT AND MORTGAGES
TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM BEING
EVICTED AND THROWN OUT IN THE
STREETS.
OUR APPROACH TO HELP AMERICANS
WHO NEED IT THE MOST WAS
NECESSARY, AND IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO, AND IT HELPED
PEOPLE AVOID FINANCIAL CRISES,
WHICH HELPED OUR WHOLE COUNTRY
AS A CONSEQUENCE OF THAT.
IT DIDN'T BENEFIT THEM, IT
BENEFITS THE WHOLE ECONOMY.
OUR APPROACH IS WHY AMERICA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WAS FASTER AND
STRONGER THAN ANY OTHER ADVANCED
NATION IN THE WORLD.
NOW IT'S TIME TO ADDRESS THE
BURDEN OF STUDENT DEBT IN THE
SAME WAY.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION, HE'S GOT
THE HARD JOB, YOU KNOW,
SECRETARY CARDONA, HERE'S WHAT
MY ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO DO
TO PROVIDE MORE BREATHING ROOM
FOR PEOPLE SO THEY HAVE LESS
BURDEN BY STUDENT DEBT, AND
QUITE FRANKLY, TO FIX THE SYSTEM
ITSELF, WHICH WE CAME IN AND WE
BOTH ACKNOWLEDGED WAS BROKEN, IN
TERMS OF -- ANYWAY, THERE ARE
THREE KEY FACTORS WE'RE GOING TO
DO TODAY, FIRST, WE MADE
INCREDIBLE PROGRESS ADVANCING
AMERICA'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
WE'VE WOUND DOWN PANDEMIC RELIEF
PROGRAMS LIKE THE ONES
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND SMALL
BUSINESSES.
IT'S TIME WE DO THE SAME THING
FOR STUDENT LOANS.
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS IS GOING
TO END.
IT'S GOING TO END DECEMBER 30th.
I'M EXTENDING TO DECEMBER 31st,
2022, AND IT'S GOING TO END AT
THAT TIME.
IT'S TIME FOR THE PAYMENTS TO
RESUME.
SECOND, MY CAMPAIGN FOR
PRESIDENT, I MADE A COMMITMENT,
I MADE A COMMITMENT THAT WE
WOULD PROVIDE STUDENT DEBT
RELIEF, AND I'M HONORING THAT
COMMITMENT TODAY.
USING THE AUTHORITY CONGRESS
GRANTED THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, WE WILL FORGIVE
$10,000 IN OUTSTANDING FEDERAL
STUDENT LOANS.
IN ADDITION, STUDENTS WHO COME
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES WHICH
ALLOWED THEM TO QUALIFY TO
RECEIVE A PELL GRANT WILL HAVE
THEIR DEBT REDUCED $20,000.
BOTH OF THESE TARGETED ACTIONS
ARE FOR FAMILIES WHO NEED IT THE
MOST.
WORKING AND MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE
HIT ESPECIALLY HARD DURING THE
PANDEMIC MAKING UNDER $125,000 A
YEAR.
YOU MAKE MORE THAN THAT, YOU
DON'T QUALIFY.
NO HIGH INCOME INDIVIDUAL OR
HIGH INCOME HOUSEHOLD ON TOP OF
THE 5% IN THE TOP 5% OF INCOMES,
BY THE WAY, WILL BENEFIT FROM
THIS ACTION PERIOD.
IN FACT, ABOUT 90% OF THE
ELIGIBLE BENEFICIARIES MAKE
UNDER $75,000 AS A FAMILY.
AND HERE'S WHAT THAT MEANS.
IF YOU MAKE UNDER $125,000, YOU
GET $10,000 KNOCKED OFF YOUR
STUDENT DEBT.
IF YOU MAKE UNDER $125,000 A
YEAR, AND YOU RECEIVED A PELL
GRANT, YOU'LL GET AN ADDITIONAL
$10,000 KNOCKED OFF THAT TOTAL
FOR A TOTAL OF $20,000 RELIEF.
95% OF THE BORROWERS CAN BENEFIT
FROM THESE ACTIONS.
THAT'S 43 MILLION PEOPLE.
OF THE 43 MILLION, OVER 60% ARE
PELL GRANT RECIPIENTS, THAT'S 27
MILLION PEOPLE WHO WILL GET
$20,000 IN DEBT RELIEF.
NEARLY 45% CAN HAVE THEIR
STUDENT DEBT FULLY CANCELLED,
THAT'S 20 MILLION PEOPLE WHO CAN
START GETTING ON WITH THEIR
LIVES.
ALL THIS MEANS, PEOPLE CAN START
FINALLY CRAWL OUT FROM UNDER
THAT MOUNTAIN OF DEBT TO GET ON
TOP OF THEIR RENT AND THEIR
YOUTHS.
TO FINALLY THINK ABOUT BUYING A
HOME OR STARTING A FAMILY OR
STARTING A BUSINESS.
AND BY THE WAY, WHEN THIS
HAPPENS, THE WHOLE ECONOMY IS
BETTER OFF.
IN THE COMING WEEKS, THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL LAY
OUT IN DETAIL, A SHORT AND
SIMPLE FORM TO APPLY FOR THIS
RELIEF ALONG WITH INFORMATION
WHEN THIS APPLICATION PROCESS
OPENS.
BY RESUMING STUDENT LOAN
PAYMENTS AT THE SAME TIME AS WE
PROVIDE TARGETED RELIEF, WE'RE
TAKING AN ECONOMICALLY
RESPONSIBLE COURSE.
AS A CONSEQUENCE, ABOUT
$50 BILLION A YEAR WILL START
COMING BACK INTO THE TREASURY
BECAUSE OF THE RESUMPTION OF
DEBT.
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS AGREE THESE
ACTIONS TAKEN TOGETHER WILL
PROVIDE REAL BENEFITS FOR
FAMILIES, WITHOUT MEANINGFUL
EFFECT ON INFLATION.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
I HEAR IT ALL THE TIME, HOW DO
WE PAY FOR IT?
WE PAY FOR IT BY WHAT WE'VE
DONE, LAST YEAR WE CUT THE
DEFICIT BY MORE THAN
$350 BILLION.
THIS YEAR WE'RE ON TRACK TO CUT
IT BY MORE THAN 1.7 TRILLION BY
THE END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR.
THE SINGLE LARGEST DEFICIT
REDUCTION IN A SINGLE YEAR IN
THE HISTORY OF AMERICA, AND THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT IS GOING
TO CUT IT BY 300 BILLION OVER
THE NEXT DECADE BECAUSE MEDICARE
WILL BE PAYING LESS FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, AND OVER A
TRILLION DOLLARS FOR THE NEXT
TWO DECADES.
THE POINT IS THIS, THERE'S
PLENTY OF DEFICIT REDUCTION TO
PAY FOR THE PROGRAMS MANY TIMES
OVER.
I WILL NEVER APOLOGIZE FOR
HELPING AMERICANS WORKING,
WORKING AMERICANS AND MIDDLE
CLASS, ESPECIALLY NOT TO THE
SAME FOLKS WHO VOTED FOR A
$2 TRILLION TAX CUT THAT MAINLY
BENEFITTED THE WEALTHIEST
AMERICANS AND THE BIGGEST
CORPORATIONS THAT SLOWED THE
ECONOMY, DIDN'T DO A HELL OF A
LOT FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH, AND
WASN'T PAID FOR AND RACKED UP
THIS ENORMOUS DEFICIT.
JUST AS WE'VE NEVER APOLOGIZED
WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GAVE
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE CENT OF OVER
$700 BILLION IN LOANS TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS AMERICA DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
NO ONE COMPLAINED THAT THOSE
LOANS CAUSED INFLATION, A LOT OF
THESE FOLKS AND SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE WORKING IN MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES.
THEY NEEDED HELP.
IT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
SO THE OUTRAGE OVER HELPING
WORKING PEOPLE WITH STUDENT
LOANS I THINK IS SIMPLY WRONG.
DEAD WRONG.
THIRD THING, WE'RE FIXING THE
STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM SYSTEM
ITSELF.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS AT
LENGTH.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
WE'RE PROPOSING TO MAKE WHAT'S
CALLED AN INCOME DRIVEN
REPAYMENT PLAN SIMPLE AND FAIR.
AND HERE'S HOW.
NO ONE WITH AN UNDERGRADUATE
LOAN TODAY OR THE FUTURE,
WHETHER FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
A FOUR-YEAR COLLEGE WILL HAVE TO
PAY MORE THAN 5% OF THEIR
DISCRETIONARY INCOME TO REPAY
THEIR LOAN.
THAT'S INCOME AFTER YOU PAY THE
NECESSITIES LIKE HOUSING, FOOD
AND THE LIKE.
YOU CURRENTLY PAY 10%.
WE'RE CUTTING THAT IN HALF TO
5%, AND AFTER YOU PAY YOUR LOAN
FOR 20 YEARS, YOUR OBLIGATION
WILL BE FULFILLED IF IT HADN'T
ALREADY BEEN FULFILLED, MEANING
YOU WON'T HAVE TO PAY ANYMORE,
PERIOD.
AND BORROWERS WHOSE ORIGINAL
BALANCE WAS LESS THAN $12,000,
MANY OF WHOM ARE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WILL BE DONE
PAYING JUST AFTER TEN YEARS.
THESE CHANGES WILL SAVE MORE
THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
ON AVERAGE FOR THE BORROWER.
IT'S A GAME CHANGER.
WE'RE ALSO FIXING WHAT'S CALLED,
AND THIS HAS BEEN THE BANE OF
DRIVING ME CRAZY WHEN I WAS OUT
OF OFFICE.
THE PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM.
NOW, THIS PROGRAM FORGIVES
STUDENT LOANS TO ENCOURAGE THOSE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE THOSE LOANS IF
THEY GO IN TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
THINK OF THE MILLIONS WHO ARE.
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS, LOCAL
POLICE OFFICERS, WORKERS AT
LOCAL CHARITIES, MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY AND NATIONAL GUARD, AND
SO MANY MORE, THINK OF THE FOLKS
WHO WORK FOR FEDERAL, STATE,
LOCAL, TRAVEL GOVERNMENTS,
KEEPING ESSENTIALLY SERVICES
GOING, RESPOND TO GO NATURAL
DISASTER, ALL OF THOSE
FIREFIGHTERS AND COPS.
THE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED SO IF
YOU SERVE IN ONE OF THESE JOBS
AND BE ABLE TO LIST THOSE AND BE
ABLE TO ACCURATELY ASSESS
WHETHER YOU DO, AND MAKE YOUR
LOAN PAYMENTS FOR TEN YEARS,
EVEN IF IT'S NOT CONSECUTIVE
YEARS, YOUR REMAINING BALANCE
WILL BE COMPLETELY FORGIVEN.
IT'S A GREAT IDEA BUT THE
PROGRAM IS A MESS.
IT'S SO INEFFICIENT, AND
COMPLICATED.
TOO MANY PEOPLE JUST GIVE UP.
THINK OF A SERVICE MEMBER DEFERS
THEIR STUDENT LOAN PAYMENT,
WHILE THEY'RE DEPLOYED.
THE SYSTEM IS SO RESTRICTIVE
THAT THEIR ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE
DIDN'T COUNT AS PUBLIC SERVICE
AND THE LOAN ISN'T FORGIVEN AS
PROMISED.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
THE MAN TO MY LEFT IS GOING TO
FIX IT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
PROPOSED CHANGES THAT WILL MAKE
THIS PROGRAM WORK BETTER AND
OVER THE LONG-TERM MUCH BETTER.
AND NOW THE DEPARTMENT ISSUES
EMERGENCY TEMPORARY CHANGES TO
RETROACTIVELY CREDIT PUBLIC
SERVICE SO IT COUNTS AND LOANS
ARE FORGIVEN.
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN OFFICE, MORE
THAN 175,000 TEACHERS, NURSES,
POLICE OFFICERS, HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GET OVER $10 BILLION IN LOAN
FORGIVENESS SO FAR THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM.
BUT THIS OPPORTUNITY EXPIRES ON
OCTOBER 31st, 2022.
SO MY MESSAGE TO ALL SERVANTS,
ALL PUBLIC SERVANTS, ALL THOSE
WHO ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
VOLUNTEERING IS OUT WITH STUDENT
DEBT TO GO.
IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT HOW TO
DO IT, GO TO PSLF.GOV BEFORE
OCTOBER 31st TO SEE IF YOU
QUALIFY FOR PUBLIC SERVICE
STUDENT LOAN FORGIVENESS.
THIS IS ANOTHER GAME CHANGER,
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE THERE TO HELP DIRECT YOU
AND WORK YOU THROUGH THE PROCESS
AND ONE MORE THING WE'RE
CHANGING TO THE SYSTEM, WE'RE
HOLDING COLLEGES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
JACKING UP COSTS, WITHOUT ADDING
VALUE TO THE STUDENTS.
ONLY TO WATCH STUDENTS BE RIPPED
OFF AND HAVE MOUNDS OF DEAD.
MY PREDECESSOR LOOKED THE OTHER
WAY.
MY ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING IT
ON.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WORKED WITH PRIVATE
EDUCATION ASSOCIATIONS TO
ACCREDITED COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES SO THEY CAN RECEIVE
FEDERAL AID.
WELL, LAST WEEK THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION FIRED A COLLEGE
ACCREDITER THAT ALLOWED COLLEGES
LIKE ITT IN CORINTHIAN TO
DEFRAUD BORROWERS, AND COMBINED
WITH OUR EMERGENCY ACTIONS, THE
PUBLIC SERVICE FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM AND OTHER ACTIONS TAKEN,
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CANCEL MORE
THAN $32 BILLION OF STUDENT DEBT
FOR 1.6 MILLION BORROWERS,
INCLUDING THOSE DEFRAUDED BY
THESE BAD ACTING SCHOOLS.
OUR GOAL IS TO SHINE A LIGHT ON
THE WORST ACTORS SO STUDENTS CAN
AVOID THESE DEBT TRAPS.
NOW, I UNDERSTAND NOT EVERYTHING
I'M ANNOUNCING TODAY IS GOING TO
MAKE EVERYBODY HAPPY.
SOMETHING IS TOO MUCH.
I FIND IT INTERESTING HOW SOME
OF MY REPUBLICAN FRIENDS WHO
VOTED FOR THOSE TAX CUTS AND
OTHERS THINK THAT WE SHOULDN'T
BE HELPING THESE FOLKS.
SOMETHING IS TOO LITTLE.
BUT I BELIEVE MY PLAN IS
RESPONSIBLE AND FAIR.
IT FOCUSES THE BENEFIT ON MIDDLE
CLASS AND WORKING FAMILIES.
IT HELPS BOTH CURRENT AND FUTURE
BORROWERS.
AND IT WILL FIX A BADLY BROKEN
SYSTEM.
AND THESE ACTIONS BUILD ON MY
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORT TO MAKE
COLLEGE MORE AFFORDABLE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
IT INCLUDES UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENTS, NEARLY 6 BILLION IN
HISTORIC BLACK COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
MUCH OF WHICH IS FOCUSED ON
PANDEMIC RELIEF TO HELP STUDENTS
COVER TUITION AND OTHER COSTS SO
THEY CAN STAY IN SCHOOL.
AND I MUST BE HONEST WITH YOU,
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR DOUBLING THE PELL GRANT.
I DIDN'T GET THAT DONE THIS
TIME.
LET ME SAY IT AGAIN.
12 YEARS OF UNIVERSAL EDUCATION
IS NOT ENOUGH.
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
FOR UNIVERSAL PRE-K FOR EVERY 3
AND 4-YEAR-OLD, AND UNIVERSAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR EDUCATION
BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL.
LET ME CLOSE WITH THIS.
I RAN FOR OFFICE TO GROW THE
ECONOMY FROM THE BOTTOM UP AND
THE MIDDLE OUT.
BECAUSE WHEN WE DO THAT,
EVERYBODY DOES BETTER.
EVERYBODY DOES WELL.
THE WEALTHY DO VERY WELL.
THE POOR HAVE A WAY UP AND THE
MIDDLE CLASS CAN HAVE BREATHING
ROOM.
AND THAT'S GOING TO HELP AMERICA
WIN THE ECONOMIC COMPETITION OF
THE 21st CENTURY BECAUSE MUCH OF
MY TIME IS SPENT HOW DO WE
REMAIN THE MOST COMPETITIVE
NATION IN THE WORLD WITH THE
STRONGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
WITH THE GREATEST OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE WORLD.
THAT'S WHAT TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT
IS ABOUT, ABOUT OPPORTUNITY,
ABOUT GIVING PEOPLE A FAIR SHOT,
ABOUT THE ONE WORD AMERICA CAN
BE DEFINED BY, POSSIBILITIES.
IT'S ALL ABOUT PROVIDING
POSSIBILITIES.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT MORE
TO SAY ABOUT THIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF MATERIAL THAT'S
GOING TO BE PUT OUT AS TO HOW
THIS IS BEING IMPLEMENTED AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL AND GOD
BLESS YOU ALL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, HOW MUCH
ADVANCED NOTICE DID YOU HAVE OF
THE FBI'S PLAN TO SEARCH
MAR-A-LAGO?
>> I DIDN'T HAVE ANY ADVANCED
NOTICE, NONE, ZERO, NOT ONE
SINGLE BIT.
THANK YOU.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, IS IT UNFAIR
TO PEOPLE WHO PAID THEIR STUDENT
LOANS OR CHOSE NOT TO TAKE OUT
LOANS?
>> THERE YOU HAVE IT, PRESIDENT
BIDEN LAYING OUT HIS CASE, LET'S
LISTEN TO HIS ANSWER HERE.
>> DO NOT OWN MULTIBILLION
DOLLAR BUSINESSES, SEE WHY THESE
GUYS GET ALL THE T